Time to say goodbye to the Google Drive app.
Google announced the backup program has three months to live.
But don't panic, it's actually not that big of a deal.
You see, the whole cloud storage space known as Google Drive, that's still alive.
What is going away is the app called Google Drive.
And that's used to back up your computer's files to the cloud.
The naming of it is all a bit messy.
Google Drive, the app, is being replaced by a program called Backup and Sync.
Now, this new program is pretty handy.
You tell it which folders on your computer you want to sync to the cloud,...
...even make all your photos and videos automatically back up to the Google Photos library.
So, you could use this to have important folders...
...to be continuously backed up to your Drive account.
But that means you will quickly exceed the 15 GBs of free space...
...and you'll need to pay for more.